je reçois maintenant nathalie provost
dont la vie a été changée à jamais par
ce drame bonsoir nathalie bonsoir dont
vous avez assisté à cette cérémonie
comment quel sentiment vous habite après
32 ans quand même ce soir
ce soir étrangement c'est le sentiment
de pointe seul il ya beaucoup de
solitude dans dans tout ce qui a entouré
les événements de polytechnique dans ma
vie et ce soir
en 32e anniversaire une journée de pluie
de température moche on était nombreux
et beaucoup avaient envie d'être là
autour de nous et moi ça me parle de
l'envy qu'en mai les jeunes et citoyens
que les choses avancent dans tout ce qui
représente les événements pour le
technique donc c'était une grande
reconnaissance pour la participation
citoyenne aujourd'hui et plusieurs des
dinka qui étaient là ont parlé du devoir
de mémoire c'est important ce devoir
domaine de mémoire encore aujourd'hui
pour vous quand on voit la situation des
féminicides on a beaucoup parlé tu au
québec mais il y en a partout au canada
quand on voit la situation
la violence par armes les morts qui ont
eu au québec mais qui a qui ont eu lieu
aussi dans d'autres grandes villes du
canada oui je crois que tous les
symboles qui entoure le 6 décembre sont
importants parce que ça nous fait
avancer parce que ça nous oblige à
regarder la réalité en face oui devoir
qui a encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
quand on parle juste des féminicides par
exemple 18 encore cette année au québec
près c'est trop
ça parle de notre vulnérabilité ça parle
aussi à quel point la pandémie a été
difficile à quel point une économie
difficile un monde qui se crispe et
parce que les inégalités sociales parce
que encore des inégalités dans les
rapports hommes femmes donc
c'est beaucoup il faut agir sur le plan
des féministes et de je pense quand même
que si ça nous révolte tous
individuellement on va peut-être agir
dans nos vies et auprès de nos proches
pour tendre la main à ceux qui ont
besoin femmes et hommes
pour ce qui est des armes
de toute la lutte pour un meilleur
contrôle de tous les types d'armes ben
monsieur trudeau ont été à nos côtés il
ce soir malgré les promesses qui nous
ont profondément déçu en mai mais pas
des promesses mais des projets de loi la
promesse électorale fait qu'on était
contente de le recevoir content de le
recevoir mais on a grand espoir
qu'ils vont livrer l'ams pleinement la
marchandise ou et vos relations étaient
pas si bonne que ça à moment donné il
était même persona non grata en fait
oublier même pas le voir c'est à cet
événement donc qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce
qu'il fût doite qu'est ce qui doit être
fait concrètement maintenant ben ce
qu'ils ont promis en campagne électorale
pour nous
particulièrement de promesses sont
importantes pour police se souvient
parce que c'est des promesses c'est pas
des promesses et des demandes
historiques
d'abord au rachat obligatoire des armes
de style d'assaut l'arrêté en conseil
c'était un pas mais pour que cette
décision le soit permanente et qu'on
voit un vrai effet sur la sécurité des
canadiens il faut en rachat obligatoire
ils l'ont promis c'est pour ça qu'ils
étaient à nos côtés aujourd'hui ils ont
aussi promis de bannir
les chargeurs à grande capacité
aujourd'hui les chargeurs sont limitées
à cinq balles mais leur capacité n'est
pas limitée elle donc on enlève une
coupe et on se retrouve avec un chargeur
de grande capacité et ils ont dit qu'ils
agiraient là dessus aussi pour nous ce
sont des engagements forts importants
qu'ils ont pris qui réponde à nos
demandes historiques mais on peut pas
être engagée dans le contrôle des armes
à feu sans voir tout le travail qui
reste à faire notamment au niveau des
armes de poing
le jeu entre municipal d'abord
provincial ensuite et pour nous c'est un
jeu un peu stérile lee les pouvoirs les
responsabilités appartiennent au
gouvernement fédéral et il faut qu'ils
aillent au bout d'eux de leur capacité
il ya toujours pris des engagements et
qu'il ait tardé à agir tardé à agir et
l'engagement pour les armes de poing ils
ne l'ont pas pris ce qu'ils ont dit même
en campagne électorale c'est qu'ils
étaient prêts à le délégué aux provinces
on pense pas que c'est le bon moment de
faire ça on pense qu'il ya encore
matière à faire au plan fédéral on va
continuer le travail avec surtout quand
on voit la prolifération d'armes aussi
illégal sont des armes dans les rues on
voit ce qui se passe dans les rues de la
moto de la métropole tous ces jeunes qui
ont été impliqués dans les événements
comme ceux-là et qui ont perdu la vie
vous le vivez comment cette montre cette
prolifération de ces armes dans les rues
il ya plus d'âme il ya plus de morts par
armes à feu dans son contexte comme
celui-là mais on est quand même pas
rendus dans une ville
c'est très inquiétant et il faut pas
prendre ça à la légère que si on prend
la légère ça va devenir dramatique et
les conditions sociales dans lesquelles
on est c'est celle là qui m'effraie
c'est qu'on a le potentiel d'aller vers
quelque chose de dramatique agissons
donc rapidement maintenant pour éviter
d'autres drames et d'autres pertes de
vie et il y a des moyens d'action il y a
des choses qui sont à faire on veut
pouvoir échanger avec le gouvernement
fédéral pour qu'il puisse aller jusqu'au
bout puis on sent que par exemple la
mairesse plantes qui étaient avec nous
ce soir d'autres mères au québec vont
vouloir travailler dans ce sens là puis
on pense qu'on est capable de faire des
avancées mais c'est maintenant qu'il
faut les faire il faut pas laisser
dégénérer la situation
elle est difficile à contrôler c'est un
marché qui peut se faire sous la
couverture le marché en ligne est
accessible aussi la problématique est
beaucoup plus complexe qu'en 1989 ça
nous f quand vous avez reçu un oui même
quatre projectiles oui faut-il le
rappeler
nathalie provost merci beaucoup d'être
passé une fort ce soit en risque d'avoir
partagé ce moment avec nous merci merci
ma kai et merci